hey guys Ryan right here Veronica so
tonight we're gonna watch the
International trailer for guardians of
the galaxy
Veronica's pumped I'm pretty pumped I
actually haven't seen any of these
movies there's more work great there's
like no Veronica no this is the first
one hmm
is it really it's the first one ah I'm
not gonna edit that out that's staying
don't even try doing alito it sounds
like all those other movies will hadn't
been done before cool I'm on the right
track then I'm not behind I liked galaxy
movies what are some galaxy movies you
appreciate Veronica well let me just say
I love fantasy if you're gonna show me
anything and take me to the movies take
me to see a fantasy movie those are my
favorite I could fulfill a few fantasies
for you if you know what I mean oh but
zing no this is the next movie in the
Marvel franchise like after the Avengers
and all and I've already seen like a few
good trailers for this movie and I hope
this one throw some surprises my way one
two and three
from the studio that brought you this
assembles more faith for me
I had no idea the universe had in store
for me
are facing an unstoppable threat you
guys are our last chance I guess we're
stuck together partners 12 billion
people growing two souls this might not
be the best idea
wipes out billions survives oh cool
nice yeah it's like the first epic
trailer of this
I was really hooked in that trailer I
feel like there's a series or something
like a but is it based off a book a
comic book comic book okay the comic
it's marble yeah such an idiot
the other trailers you haven't seen them
but the other trailers are more like
comedic and stuff this is the first like
really serious one I kind of missed some
of that comedy but I it's cool it's like
it's cool seeing like okay last one just
look like fun comedic stuff now this
one's like heavy drama and I hope this
movie has a good balance of both of
those things you got a [ __ ] talking
raccoon for [ __ ] sake and you got to
have a good balance of humor can't just
take the talking raccoon seriously what
are the talking raccoon first you got
captured then you can make a lot of
money off of it releases public you know
what I mean then the raccoon one day
breaks loose keep eyeing burgers in
Michigan
please I'm not interested sorry
uh-huh story's over he went away and has
never returned okay mr. Issa if you're
near the channel can you subscribe
anyway we're gonna get some shoutouts
Sam mega X 141 he said on the spoiler
review of x-men Days of Future past good
review Ryan huh he didn't acknowledge
Lauren or Jerry just me and Adam reveal
thanks buddy can you please give me a
shout-out please
well buddy you deserved it you earned it
if there's ever like another person in
the frame with me but you only really
focus on me that is a true fan rated you
weren't a thumbs-up my friend I don't
know I feel about this
let's just hope I seriously outshine him
in this video Jimmy one for 173 he said
and I quote I [ __ ] love your videos a
shout-out
would make my entire year you do some of
the best videos and deserve all the
success you were having right now and
right now i imagining sucking your [ __ ]
long and deep shrugging the head of your
penis and it just goes on like that for
about six paragraphs well we like her
chef happy Jimmy
no well Aguilar Ryan can I have a
shout-out Thanks oh good okay one shadow
thank you very much you know what one
day people have to do more than just ask
who knows who knows what I'll make them
do you should have them like send you a
video or something you're like that's
what I want a collection of videos I do
a contest for your subscribers or
something like that I'd be fun that'd be
fun what con no no L know no hell yo
buddy think of a contest I could come up
with with the subscribers you know like
maybe one of them gets to see Veronica
States
I said all right let's say yes